حصلت الجزيره على مشاهد تظهر عناصر الجيش
الاسرائيلي اثناء تفخيخ منازل فلسطينيه في
قطاع غزه وذلك قبل استهدافهم في الهجوم
الذي وقع او اوقع اكثر من 20 ضابطا وجنديا
قتل وقالت كتائب القسام ان هذه المشاهد تم
الاستحواذ عليها من قبل عناصر القسام من
كاميرات جنود اسرائيليين بعد استهدافهم
وكشف مصدر قيادي في القسام تفاصيل عمليه
التفجير شرقيه المغازي وقال ان المقاتلين
تمركزوا منذ اسابيع في منطقه العمليه شرق
المغازي رغم القصف الشديد والمتواصل واوضح
المصدر القيادي في القسام ان التعليمات
كانت بعدم التعامل مع القوات المتوغلة
حتى ظن انها اصبحت امنه فادخل قوات
الهندسه كما اشار المصدر القيادي في
القسام الى ان المقاتلين رصدوا القوه
المعاديه تتقدم وتم تشخيصه على ان قوه
هندسيه عبر هويتها ومعداتها واثر عدم
التعامل مع قوه راجله اخرى كانت تقف فوق
حقل الغام اعدته القسام مسبقا وكشف المصدر
القيادي في القسام ان مقاتلي القسام
انتظروا انهاء القوه عملها وتثبيت
المتفجرات ثم استهدفوه بقذيفه مضاده
للافراد حيث كانت القذيفه بمثابه محرض
للمتفجرات التي احدثت انفجارا دمر المبنى
وقضى على افراد القوه وقال المصدر القيادي
في القسام انه بالتوازي مع ذلك تم تدمير
دبابه كانت تعمل على تامين القوه وتم قتل
واصابه من فيها
وختم المصدر القيادي في القسام بالقول انه
بعد وصول قوات نجده للمكان ومرورها فوق
حقل الالغام تم تفجيره ثم انسحب المقاتلون
بسلام وفي الوقت الذي تشهد فيه جميع
المحاور في خان يونس اشتباكات ضاريه كثفت
قوات الاحتلال قصفها لمناطق مركز الثقل في
جنوب القطاع واستهدفت المستشفيات في
المنطقه بما فيها مجمع ناصر الطبي ومراكز
ايواء اللاجئين ما اسفر عن سقوط شهداء
وجرحه وفي خط موازن ايضا اعلنت كتائب
القسام ان مقاتليها تمكنوا من استهداف قوه
اسرائيليه مؤلفه من اكثر من 15 جنديا
تحصنوا داخل منزل غرب خانيونس جنوب قطاع
غزه وتم ايقاع جميعا بين قتيل وجريح كما
اعلنت استهداف تسع اليات اسرائيليه منها
دبابات ميركافا وناقله جند وجرافات في
محيط خان يونس كما استهدفت القسام القوات
المتوغلة
خانيونس